yeah man a lot of traffic today go to
analyze we are on our way to the
trampoline park
somehow Matt convinced us to go and I'm
slightly terrified of terpenes so I
don't know what I'm doing here
what do you mean somehow like this is
going to be fun I hope it's going to be
fun you're gonna do backflips and front
flips and twisty flips and double flips
and water man stands are great just get
a film for everyone we'll see hope we
like that I like that
we're getting close for sure we're on
we're in the final stretch I'd say I'm
gonna get so wild I'm gonna get so
ripped and shredded
let's go that's a Chauncey yeah I don't
have I don't have it either and I really
need it how I focus on jumping on a
trampoline when there's a little fat egg
Pokemon out there this is so upsetting
like what do we do guys my future claim
is definitely coming back oh go on
what have I done
not what's the objective for today well
here call me where we going yeah
is there like jumping etiquette like do
I jump
okay we gonna do it
I don't know wall you can go straight in
if you want
not quite that but no one was there
let me tell you what I'm not gonna be
doing that
oh five foot six nine seconds it was
awful hey what they're guys I got 20
seconds
guys I just wanna mark today as the day
that Matt just got asked if he was extra
speed
Oh
far you know I don't think I'm gonna go
to do it though
see they will be fine
just really jump land and jump
that's all okay all right
a lot of children this is the king they
just got really crowded all of a sudden
I'm just gonna have to go for it
I thought I was cool a little bit but
not even close
okay I can do that okay okay try to get
me I can do that I think you can right
now I think you can jump across this
Bravo first right
and I think it was an extremely
successful trampoline park experience
yes we got a lead the front flip and
back foot I think it was great you guys
exceeded all expectations on front flips
always good stuff
pictures turner my camera right now do
it
right now we're Portillo's apparently
it's a really famous place in Chicago is
that what it's sorry it is we're here
we've never been here before no we like
George I've never been to an Olive
Garden either how is it possible I stick
to McDonald's and Burger King or
something like that I just don't eat
fast food that often oh but it's in like
it's in like the Fridays Applebee's like
that sort of given the proper tax it's
like one step up a little bit quicker my
go-to was always California Pizza
Kitchen I was going on so Jenna does
meat meat are basically in there so
let's get her proper cake show peep show
I have two pieces of property I would
like a cheeseburger okay she's rusty
wants a cheeseburger I'll do a breaded
chicken club and let's probably love it
I can't speak for the breaded chicken
club because then you know if I if I had
a suggested Italian beef from its
Chicago time for her last night okay
am I missing anything hello I will be
your report a low score guy I don't know
chicken club sandwich
thank you might be a hammer
hi nice smell it smell it chicken it's
just mine I got a burger looks burger
looks like over here
well Portillo's was delicious I have
never been there before it kind of
tasted a little bit like Wendy's of
course I did get a burger so I didn't
build a little hot dog howling Matt said
we're heading home now
gotta go get Matty because he's probably
got a good party I don't just spare you
guys the trouble of telling me
everything that I'm doing wrong with
this installation because I don't want
to hear it